hello everyone and welcome to a most
aggressive game uh from round one of the
paris rapid and blitz tournament it's
the second stage of the 2021 grand
chester uh it's a series of five events
with a total price fund of 1.275 million
dollars and
this uh is the game uh like i said from
round one so it's a really
uh it's a really crazy attacking game
but uh
there's one thing that's very
interesting about this game but i'm
going to mention this only at the pause
the video moment so
uh without further ado let's check it
out um we're going to talk a little bit
more more about the tournament
uh after uh we we show a game from round
one but basically as usual it's three
days of rapid and then two days of blitz
uh and for those of you who still
haven't joined the tournament for
tomorrow
i'm having my birthday arena uh the the
all the info is in the description below
so do join us we're going to have a lot
of fun
so getting to this game yeah teamwork
versus
opens with d4 that we have knight to f6
c for e6 and now knight to f3 and the d5
so normal queens gambit declined
uh knights to c3 and the bishop to be
for the aragos in defense we have bishop
to g5
uh and now the captures on c4 going for
the vienna variation
so as black uh captured on c4 he allowed
white to grab the center so this is
exactly what taymor does and now
c5 striking in the center with it with a
flank pawn uh we have bishop captus and
c4
c capture sunday for knight captures and
now
uh well bishop captures and c3 is the
most played move here here um
level one goes queen to a5 and it makes
sense you have a double attack on the c3
knight
also you're now pressuring the bishop on
g5 you've unpinned as
uh your queen was on d8 so it makes
sense to go for this
uh so well you could go back and this
might be a bit more
uh interesting uh here rajabov decides
to trade we have bishop captures on f6
uh
g and not g captures but first bishop
captures and c3 would
check b captures and queen captures and
c3 would
check and this is very interesting
because the queen here
hits everything the king is in check the
rook is under attack the bishop is under
attack the knight is under attack so
uh what will what will the black queen
do with king the f1
uh the only good move for white and then
now g captures on f6
you might be thinking but why not
capture the bishop with check
and only then capture the bishop on f6
well you could
do this after king g1 and g captures on
f6 uh
rook to c1 just wins the game for white
that's why this is a really really
crazy line and there's no way for you to
defend this bishop you have to move the
queen somewhere it doesn't really matter
where here we're just going to capture
this bishop then we're going to capture
the rook
and that's all there is not much to
to play for here so instead after king
to f1 g captures on f6
this is the uh the best move and now
rook to c1 so now the queen is attacked
but at least
the bishop is here so you don't have to
worry about this so here queen to a5 the
queen
can always go back to d8 if needed and
now
you move the bishop with tempo so here
bishop to b5 check
we're still going to grab this bishop
with with check or if the king moves
we're just going to uh you know defend
it with a rook so king the e7 by levon
now the rook is defending the bishop
here
and now comes the only again good move
for white and that is e5
here and this is now a really crazy
position because what is
white doing uh if this is attacked just
uh
if captures on e5 then the knight will
be under attack that defends the bishop
and then how will how will white
survival of this the king is on f1 the
rook has no ways of
entering the game uh the queen nicely
covers everything so you don't have any
rook lifts or
it's a it's a very interesting position
uh problem is if black
is not careful black plays something
like bishop to d7 and
he says okay i'm not going to touch your
pawn i'm just going to continue
development
uh well he loses on the spot there's
knight to f5
check it's a really really awesome stuff
e captures on f5 and now queen to d6
with
check and once the king moves now comes
to rook the c8 the bishop is pinned you
cannot move it
uh you have to give up your queen and
then we just play captures captures and
that's it
white has simply too much material queen
captures with check you're still
going to capture the rook king c7 and
now just queen captures an h8 let's say
bishop captures on b5 with czech king he
won
and you can to develop the knight the
rook would hang and here uh the queen
and rook would
easily win the game so instead after e5
uh we have f captures an e5 level and
says all right i know this line i i know
what you are doing
uh and here now the knight is under
attack if you move the knight you lose
the bishop
but here uh rajavo goes queen to h5
and what happens here what happens if
you capture the knight
well if you capture the knight then
notice that the queen here
is aligned with the black queen so can
we do something about this
probably not but we do have queen to g5
with
check and now what do you do uh the the
bishop slices over this way the queen
slices over this way so
the black king really doesn't have all
that many squares you can go here and
you can go here
and if you go here then it's just queen
to c5 with checkmate
so that doesn't work if you go to f8 uh
it's not much better we're just going to
play rook captures and c8 with
check and once the queen blocks as there
are no squares this is covered by the
white queen
we have to block and then this is
checkmate so uh
we cannot do that we have to block by
playing uh after this queen to h5
uh uh queen to h5 uh uh uh sorry after
queen to h5 we can't uh capture the
knight
because then uh this uh queen to g5
check we only have f6 here
and then queen to c5 with check is
enough for
for white to win the game king to f7 and
now there's this bishop to e8 to check
which now allows us to win the black
queen so it is possible queen bishop
eight
checking captures queen captures an a5
so uh
there is the possibility of taking
advantage of this if
you captured the knight so here we have
knight to d7 by lavon
and now queen to g5 with check again
f6 here not possible you're just going
to play queen g7 check and after the
king moves we're going to play
rook captures on c8 remove the defender
of the knight here and that's just it
we're going to easily win the game here
even if you block it like this okay
you're guarding the knight now but now
we can capture this rook and again if
the real captures we're just going to
capture the knight here
so instead after a queen to g5 we have
kinked f8 getting away uh from check
this way but now again just removing the
defender of the uh
d7 knight so rook captures on c8 we have
rook captures and the bishop captures on
d7
attacking the rook here uh the c1 square
is covered by the queen so there are no
checks here
uh so queen to d8 was played this is the
only good move for black and now you're
white here what do you play there's only
one good move for white so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
the best way to continue for white while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding
either queen captures an e5 but this is
very very dangerous but for those of you
who found knight
captures an e6 congratulations as this
is the way to go
uh the problem with queen captures on d5
although
maybe playable you allow rook to see one
check and then after king e2 you lose
the rook on h1
so we capture this rook with check and
after the king moves we're going to
capture the queen here
with check king captures now the bishop
is under attack so we move it
and we do have two pieces for a rook but
rook captures here
and it's uh it's uh well
it's hard to say but if anyone's better
here it's still black
so knight captures on e6 is more precise
it comes with
check so now the knight has to be
captured otherwise black loses the queen
so f captures an e6 and here rajab of
played queen to h6 with
check and this is this is a really
really great
uh because uh if you go to king king to
j then bishop captures an e6's checkmate
the king has nowhere to go now
so there's only one square for the black
king that is king the e7 end and now
comes queen
captures on e6 so really really a
remarkable position
king to f8 and now queen back to h6 with
check here uh there is no way to
continue the attack because if you
capture the rook
queen to d1 will be checkmate for black
so you have to continue happily checking
the
the black king so queen to h6 check king
the e7 with queen the e6 check king to
f8
queen to h6 king the e7 and here
uh after queen the e6 check it was in
this position on 25 that
uh the that rajava and agreed to a draw
or rather it was a draw by threefold
repetition so while it seems like an
incredibly crazy game
and this is yet another one of the
arranged
draws as uh for example if you look at
this position after queen to d8
this knight captures an e6 it seems like
everything up until this point was
really really incredible and it was a
brutal game
but there are uh at least what i've
found there are at least
46 top level games that reached this
exact same position so
nothing new uh but i thought it was an
interesting game so i decided to show it
to you guys as
i don't know if you've seen it already
but it's it's a good one to
uh to know so really really uh a nice
one
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh they they finished it
pretty quickly but
uh you guys will be following all the
games do use hashtag suggestion to
suggest me
suggest your favorite games and then
we're gonna cover them as well and like
i said
do uh check all the info in the
description below join us tomorrow on
the tournament we're gonna have a very
nice time
uh with the arena and uh you know uh
maybe you
you you beat some very very strong
players like i said in the previous
video
uh why wouldn't you you're you're a
great player so
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank john austin
ben blackburn
uh and atul dhingra for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day